قبل نهائي مونديال روسيا 2018 بايام غطى
كريستيانو رونالدو على اكبر هدف رياضي
باخبار رحيله عن ريال مدريد وقتها النادي
الذي قضى فيه تسعه اعوام بين صفوفه بانضمه
ليوفنتوس الايطالي هذا الاسبوع وكان
التاريخ يعيد نفسه فقبل ايام من كاس
العالم في قطر يتصدر رونالدو تريند
الرياضي العالمي بتصريحات عاصفه يشكو فيها
وضعه مع نادين مانشستر يونايتد ليله الاحد
نشر اول مقتطف من لقائه مع الاعلام
البريطاني بيرسمورجن يفتحوا فيها رونالدو
قلبه ويسطن اداره يونايتد التي لم تكن على
علم بتجيله المقابله من الاساس رونالدو
يقول انه يشعر بالخيانه من قبل يونايتد
يشعر ان النادي لم يحترمه يفتح النار على
الجميع
وجعلت من عوده بدون لقائمه الفريق ضرب من
دروب المستحيل بعد رحله امجاد متبادله
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
باي باي
الثاني عشر من اغسطس عام 2003 ينتقل
كريستيانو رونالدو ابن ال 18 الى مانشستر
يونايتد ليكون اغلى مراهق في تاريخ كره
القدم الانجليزيه وتبدا احدى امتع القصص
في تاريخ الكره بشكل عام في كاس العالم
2006 رونالدو ضمن صفوف البرتغال التي
تواجه انجلترا هنا يتسبب في طرد وان روني
زميلي في مانشستر يونايتد ليعود لانجلترا
يواجه هجوم الصحافه واستهجان جماهير
الشياطين الحمر لكنه واصل الموسم وانهى
افضل لاعب في البطوله اشتهر رونالدو بعدم
قدرته في السيطره على غضبه وارتكب حماقات
في الملعب حين غادر رونالدو ناديها عام
2009 غدره الى ريال مدريد ضلت جماهير
يونايتد على امل اللقاء مجددا لكن رحلته
التاليه حطت في ايطاليا لكنه يعود لفريق
الطفوله بعد طول انتظار في سن السادسه
والثلاثين
استقبلوه كما لم يغب يوما ابتلعت الجماهير
مفاوضاتي طوال الصيف الماضي مع افضل انديه
اوروبا سمحته عندما ترك الملعب مغادرا
اعتراضا على عدم مشاركته في احدى مباريات
الدوري وسامحت حتى تراجع مستواه اليوم
وبعد ان خفت السحر وانخفضت اللياقه وضلت
الاقدام طريقها نحو المرمى يقرر رونالدو
جدول انتباه بحوار ناري يهاجم فيه مسئوليه
الفريق بينما لا يزال في الصفوفه ويخسره
اول ترافيلد ربما من الابد
[موسيقى]
معنى هنا في الاستوديو مفاجاه مراسل صباح
العربيه في روسيا عبد الجواد رشاد وهو في
الجانب الاخر من الصحفي المتخصصين في
الشان الرياضي عبد الجواد اولا الحمد لله
على السلامه
وثانيا اهلا وسهلا فيكم مجددا في بيتك وفي
صباح العربيه
هل فعلا تراجعت شعبيه
اليوم بين كريستيانو رونالدو فريق مانشستر
يونايتد الا انه يعتبر
التاريخ
الشخصيه الصغير ماديرا هذا الصاروخ الذي
خرج من البرتغال ونافسه نجوم البرازيل
الارجنتين المانيا ايطاليا اسبانيا ووضع
بصمه صريحه له في عالم كره القدم
عقليه كره القدم وفهمها بشكل كبير ان لا
يحترمك رشيان رونالدو اللاعب قدم الكثير
لكره القدم ان كان في الدوري الانجليزي او
الايطالي او الاسباني او مع منتخب بلاده
تصوري ان لاعب برتغاليه نال اللقب خمر
يعني خمسه كره ذهبيه في العالم يقارن بها
النجوم الكبار اسماء كبيره يعني
رونالدينيو رونالدو البرازيلي ليونيل ميسي
اسماء كبيره كره القدم
لم توجد بطوله دخلها كريستيانو رونالدو
ولم يترك بها بصمه واضحه اما تسجيل اهداف
رائعه
بارقام قياسيه في عدد التسجيل وعدد
التمريرات افضل لاعب لقب بطوله اوروبا
دوري ابطال اوروبا يعني نحتاج لحلقه كامله
للحديث عن القاب كريستيانو رونالدو
طب اليوم الى اي حد سيؤثر على التيمور
يعني زملائه نفسه من زوجين منه
وصل لهذا العمر من الزمن واعتقد ان
انتقاله وعودته لفريق مانشستر يونايتد هي
خطا نوعا ما باعتبار ان الفريق الذي يعمل
معه مدير عمله لم يقم بهذه الحسابات
الكبيره فريق مانشستر يونايتد هو فريق
عريق فريق الشياطين الحمر لديه قاعده
شعبيه في انجلترا وفي اوروبا وفي العالم
لا يستهان بها الدوري الانجليزي معروف
بقوته وكرامته وكريستيانو رونالدو قبل
دخوله وعودته للدوري الانجليزي قد ما يعني
فتره في الدوري الايطالي لم تكن من افضل
السنوات التي لعب بها يعني الجميع يتذكر
كيف كان اداء بكم عندما خرج من تلك
الدوريات القويه نحو القاره الامريكيه كان
فريقه اذكى بكثير مما فعله كريستيانو
رونالدو لذلك ما نلاحظه وما يعني ما وضع
كريستيانو رونالدو في هذا الموضع اليوم هو
طبعا محاوله اخيره باعتبار انه المنجال
الاخيره لكريستيانو رونالدو وكريستيانو
رونالدو يعني يمكن تميزه عن باقي اللاعبين
ناديين هو شخص مشتهد جدا يعني لا يملك تلك
المهارات التي يتمتع بها راقصوا التانجو
او
البرازيليين او الارجنتين او الاسبانيه او
هو مجتهد يعني يقوم بالعمل على نفسه في
فتره طويله من الزمن طيب عبد الجواد في
فلسفه بالحيا يعني بكل مجالات العمل
بيقولوا لك مش مهم كيف تدخل هذا المجال
المهم كيف تخرج الخروج بنفس القلق وبنفس
الهيبه شو اللي صار مع رونالدو يعني كل
هالسنين وانت بلشت حديثك بتمدح بتاريخ
ومصيرته الرياضيه اليوم وكانه عم بيحاول
يقضي عليها في نهايه مصيرته يعني فهم
رياضي لهذا الموضوع كريستيانو لم يتحدث من
الفراق يعني اصحاب النادي وملك النادي اخر
همهم هي النتائج الرياضيه الكبيره اليوم
على الطاوله وخاصه في ظل الوضع الذي يعيش
على العالم هو الاراده التي ياتي بها
مانشستر يونايتد الاخيره يعني تحدث عن
الحقيقه في هذا الموضوع كريستيانو رونالدو
ذاهب للبحث عن فرصه واخرى تبقيه في عالم
النجوميه ولو لسنوات قليله بعد اليوم هو
كان قد تحدث سابقا منه قد يلعب كره القدم
لغايه عمر يعني يزداد عن الاربعين عاما
لكن النتائج الاخيره له في مانشستر
يونايتد وفي الدوري الايطالي بعد خروجه من
الدوري الاسباني يعني وضعت له الحدود في
عمر كره القدم لكن نقطه مهمه نادين نجيب
الحديث عنها بان افضل الانديه التي
استفادت من كريستيانو رونالدو هو فريق
ريال مدريد يعني قام بشرائه من مانشستر
يونايتد بصفقه كانت في حينها الاغلب في
العالم وباعه بنفس الثمن بعد ان استفاد
منه لسنوات طويله في تحقيق الالقاب
والكؤوس والميداليات والارقام وتجيء لها
في عالم الساحر المستدير
بل ايضا بالشؤون الرياضيه عبد الجواد رشاد
شكرا لك